so against this backdrop we find
ourselves in an unprecedentedly serious
and dangerous situation and the
consequences are to a large extent
unpredictable that is why I have today
invited Mr Luke divinian to give us an
overview of the recent developments and
on the on the all the issues I have
mentioned and then we will have as I
have already announced a roughly 50 55
minutes for an exchange of views
since this is a joint meeting with our
city subcommittee I would like to ask
for Secretariat is any City
representative here if that's not the
case without further Ado I give the
floor to Mr Davina please
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
to you and honorable members of the
European Parliament ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much for
inviting um European external Action
Service
and is indeed as you mentioned tragic
circumstances
and the latest escalation uh steps taken
by by Russia
um
we were very pleased to see European
Parliament and your committee Mr
chairman in particular playing an
important role in calling for strong
and concrete support to Ukraine
and also for robust sanctions against
Russia I knew Mr chairman as well as
honorable members versus
condemned last week the holding of these
sham referenda the subject of our
meeting today first what did we see in
in the last few days in in the last week
last Thursday was marking the seventh
month
um since Russia has started its brutal
unjustified invasion of an independent
country Ukraine
independence of which it never contested
during 31 years should I add
and it has been seven months also that
Ukraine has been defending itself
bravely and successfully and recently
you have seen that it has managed to
push back the Russian army in liberating
some territories from the Russian
occupation unfortunately this has
allowed to discover Mass Graves that we
had seen earlier in butcher it had been
borodianca and that we are now seeing in
new places like izum
thousands of civilians have been
murdered and many more of them have been
beaten tortured harassed sexually
assaulted kidnapped forcibility or
forcibly displaced
Russia will have to be held accountable
as you were mentioning in your
introduction for all the suffering that
this war has brought upon the Ukrainian
people
last Friday the commission of inquiry on
Ukraine presented their findings to the
United Nations Human Rights Council
documenting war crimes committed by
Russia in Ukraine
we will do whatever it takes to ensure
accountability we rely of course on the
international criminal court and also on
the Ukrainian authorities and we are
supporting both financially and
assisting also materially the office of
the Ukraine prosecutor General on
providing training expertise equipment
and also collecting evidence
Ukraine has managed to withstand the
aggression by Russia and it's been
possible thanks to the braver Ukraine
people but also it's been possible
through the support political financial
and Military that a European union and
its like-minded Partners have granted to
Ukraine
considering the absence of military
successes President Putin is now
continuing along a very sad path of
escalation and is trying to not only
intimidate Ukraine but also all the
countries that support Ukraine
Russia has announced it was mobilizing
hundreds of thousands of new uh
conscripts although it was claiming
officially that the only had lost six
thousand soldiers so there's a bit of a
contradiction here
and according to official announcements
mobilization would apply to 3 300 000
reservists
however uh parts of the decree remain
secret and we don't know what the exact
numbers will be at the same time
Minister of Defense shogu stated that
there were almost 25 million such men in
Russia which of course seems exaggerated
but nevertheless talking of partial
mobilization may be actually some form
of propaganda to reassure the people
that the problems are much bigger than
what it is officially acknowledged
secondly Russia is now conducting the
Sham referenda in Donetsk legazon in the
Parisa regions even if it's far from
militarily controlling all of them
trying to repeat the well-known 2014
Crimea scenario
and thirdly and this is to be read in
conjunction with the previous Point
Russia has been also threatening again
with the use of weapons of mass
destruction against Ukraine
and using even the platform of the
United Nations General Assembly last
week where world leaders were assembling
I should add that the only good news of
last week was the prisoners exchange
215 Ukraine's versus 55 Russians were
unfortunately more than 2 000 Ukraine's
remain prisoners as well
now what has been the European Union
reaction to this latest escalatory steps
you have seen the very quick and very
firm statements by the high
representative by eu27 by G7 leaders and
we have also coordinated our reaction
with our partners and allies
our message is triple one we will not
recognize those sham referenda and
obviously not their results
secondly we are actively examining new
restrictive measures in reaction to this
escalation
and thirdly any reference to nuclear
weapons or threats against nuclear power
plants which Russia is cynically
bombarding are pushing Russia to the
margins of civilized Nations
our representative condemned this as is
irresponsible and cynical attempt to
undermine our steadfast supports to
Ukraine but the Russian threats do not
Shake our determination resolve and
unity to stand by Ukraine as long as it
will take
we have been clear that those who are
involved with these so-called referenda
will be held accountable and this will
be the subject of also the additional
restrictive measures
we have also announced last week in an
extraordinary meeting of fun Affairs
ministers in New York that we would
continue or even increase our military
support to Ukraine and we have so far
supported miniature assistance and there
are European peace facility and we
intend to propose a new trash sooner
also preparation have intensified to
define the parameters for new EU
military assistance mission to Ukraine
thirdly the reactions of the Russian
Society the ongoing mobilization is
quite amazing we have seen in a few days
thousands of Russian citizens
taking the streets and protesting
despite the very brutal repression and
the very serious threats that the risk
of being sent to prison or being beaten
Etc
more than two thousand have support have
so far been detained during this protest
but we also have seen many more Russians
voting or protesting with protesting
with their feet by leaving their country
and we have seen the land the queues at
the land borders of Russia with
Kazakhstan with Georgia with Mongolia
with Azerbaijan stretching for
kilometers in kilometers
we also have observed the skyrocketing
prices of flights to leave Russia or
their mayor an availability
fourth
um the way ahead we believe that um
this escalatory steps show signs of a
certain crisis critical movement at
least
first
the Ukraine Army is continuing its
counter-offensive liberating New Towns
and villages
and we have seen that since the morale
in the Russian army is probably very low
President Putin decided to change the
legislation by toughening the sentences
for uh surrendering criminalizing it or
refusal to serve in the army with up to
10 years prison sentence
secondly our sanctions our economic
sanctions do work
Russia is facing its worst recession
since the 90s the GDP is expected to
drop by over 11 percent
which is even bigger than uh since the
collapse of the Soviet Union the largest
drop
thirdly internationally Russia is more
and more even merely diplomatically but
very firmly isolated
and even
so-called allies like China
or more recently also India important
Partners have have declared that today's
era is not an era of War
and clearly also expressing concerns
Turkish president erdogan also urged to
end the war and stated publicly that the
lands which were invaded will be
returned to Ukraine
at the same time we see also nationalist
circles inside Russia protesting as well
so we believe that for us for the
European Union this means that are
resolved must be as strong as possible
and must continue
we have supported Ukraine also through
the Black Sea grain initiative
facilitated by United Nations Secretary
General gutesh and turkey
we have also developed the so-called
solidarity Lane facilitating exports
from Ukraine's into the EU this has also
helped the World by lowering Global food
prices and contrary to what Russian
propaganda would like to Pro to to
pretend the Russian food prices do not
increase because of the sanctions but
because of the war that they are waging
so let me just conclude uh by saying
that as encoding High representative
Burrell
I will say it in French because it was
an interview in French
now is not the time to weaken when it
comes to Ukraine thank you Mr Divina for
your valuable comments and now I will
open the floor for members
and we begin with Mikhail Gala who's our
standing Rapport thank you very much I
share your description and condemnation
I need not repeat to that
um there was this informal foreign
Minister's meeting in the united in the
margins of United Nations and you also
refer to
a new restrictive measures incoming is
that deliberate yet you do not call it
sanctions or only restrictive measures
uh will the next October Council
formalize it and can you go into more
details what we are aiming at in this
respect
um on the
implementation of the sanctions that
have already been
agreed have you got an overview where we
stand in this regard for instance the
coal Imports have they really stopped
throughout the EU do we already see a
sufficient substantial reduction of oil
imports uh is to be ended I think if I'm
not mistaken by the end of the year
um do you see when we say and it's not
the moment to to get weaker with the
last words of the high rep
we need to continue of course supplying
Ukraine with weapons but I think it also
requires that in this in the member
states the ammunition production has to
be substantially increased do you see
that is there a coordination mechanism
where you push and or look into these
realities on the ground in the member
states I'm a bit afraid that at some
point we might not be able to to step up
our support and what about the
discussion of fighter tanks ongoing uh
well of course especially in Germany but
this discussion 200 2000 leper tanks are
available in 13 countries if we get 200
delivered in a coordinated effort other
activities from your side to encourage
such thoughts in different member states
thank you
thank you I would suggest that we have
one round of comments and questions and
then hand over to look to Vineyard the
next on my list would be for the Epp
Andrea scrabillius
well thanks a lot for description of
really of that picture which
is
is quite quite uh boring
uh
I will not repeat what Michelle have
said but my question would be very
simple
you know since we watched you know
successful military offensive of
ukrainians recently in harikov region
it became very clear that you know
ukrainians with our you know support of
military weapons are able to achieve
Victory you know as soon as possible and
it depends once a war went it depends on
how much of weapons we are able to
deliver to ukrainians
and then you know of course we are
repeating and repeating that we are
supporting I see you you know but if you
are looking into the numbers I don't
know exactly the numbers but through you
know peace facility we are delivering we
we are financing around of 2.5 billion
you know uh Euros for weapons deliveries
it's not very clear how much you know
member states are doing outside of you
know peace facility but it's not very I
doubt if if those numbers are very big
on another side Americans you know
decided much earlier in the year to
provide 40 billion support as I
understand now they are discussing
another building of 12 billion so the
picture is you know very clear Americans
are doing the job
where are you now on the European
continent we are looking we are
supporting we are saying solidarity you
know what's and so on but we are not
doing the job and I agree with
absolutely with Michelle we are not
asking our industry you know to increase
production
so my question is really when will when
we see that you know picture which is
really brings a lot of you know worries
and also stress about nuclear and so on
the only way how we can speed up you
know the end of the war is to deliver
weapons so are we able to reach the
level at least to match to American you
know or should we or that is our own
destiny to look how Americans are
resolving issues on the European
continent
thank you with somebody from the snd
like to take the floor
Please Mr shimashevich thank you chair
thank you Mr Devine for your information
however there are still many issues
which deserve to be touched or deepened
and it's not very difficult to foresee
the events in in coming days this week
this is probably going to be a very
special week in modern history uh I
understand that the results of fake
referenda which have been on the Putin's
desk for a long time are going to be
announced then we can expect the
decision of incorporating those parts of
Ukraine to Russia which is going to be
confirmed by two chambers of sub-called
Russian Parliament and then of course
they will declare a different narrative
that they are going to present Ukraine
is as an aggressor
against Russia against Russian territory
that will of course allow them in their
mind to use their so-called defense
Doctrine including use of nukes uh what
is our reaction to be if those uh easily
forecasted developments uh really take
place I'm afraid that condemning that is
not sufficient it's not enough you said
Mr davini that
there is I understand uh mechanisms of
studying possible uh new restrictions or
or means to use against Russia however
let me say that last package of
sanctions in my personal opinion was
already symbolical and meaningless if we
continue to to act like that
we are going to we are risking to be
totally ineffective and what about uh
what about that possibility of use of
nuclear weapons for the first time as I
understand Mr President zielinski said
that Putin is not laughing usually he
tried to downplay the risks today he
says that
if that happens
what will be the EU reaction I
understand that United States and UK are
especially responsible as cosigners of
Budapest memorandum but are there any
consultations between us and them or we
are are we just waiting for the
developments of the situation what about
Russian conscripts or potential
conscripts trying to leave this country
many member states decided not to accept
them not to allow them in my opinion
it's a mistake everything that
everything that we can put in and
Russia's Army should be
understood as something positive not
forever not as Asylum Seekers but just
for the time when the danger
endangered this is two ways to eliminate
those people as our enemies either to
equip ukrainians to kill them in the
battle or to let them to come to our
countries we'll not have them in the
front of of this war
so um
are we able as the European Union
considering Urban's position and policy
considering the results of elections in
Sweden and Italy to adopt
a strong common position and reaction to
all those potentially very very
dangerous developments in Ukraine thank
you
thank you
just to inform you we have in the moment
six more colleagues who would like to
take the floor
can you please raise your hands now
we have natural
seven do you want to do two rounds or
Sergey viola
I think everyone in the room has now
requested to take the floor
Mr davidia would you like to do one or
two rounds no I will do it now okay well
let's have uh at least one more group uh
take the floor now Mr Beautiful
thank you chair thank you Mr Davina for
your valuable remarks
indeed as the chair said in the
beginning we are facing an unprecedented
situation and the um
development of events is indeed
unpredictable
but at the same time
we should and must be firm in our
determination
to indeed
support Ukraine actively as long as it
takes on all fronts
and I agree with uh Mr kobilius that
in this situation
we have to increase that support in all
the different dimensions
by the way just one side remark
regarding China
I'm not sure that China is unhappy
or is concerned with the fact that Putin
is Waging War
I'm rather of the opinion that China is
unhappy that he's not winning the war
that's how I read their position
as regards the different dimensions
of this fight and our contribution to
that
number one should be and I uh
can only reiterate what Mikhail Gala
said we have to make sure that the
sanctions that are in place
are indeed enforced
and we must also
demand from the member states
governments that they should see to it
that these sanctions are enforced
second
as we see the sanctions
the present level of sanctions
is already having an impact in Russia
and I would I would support further
sanctions but I'm not sure that
increasing the level of sanctions will
have a decisive effect
because Putin is not motivated by
economic rationale he's motivated by
imperialist thinking and he's willing to
sacrifice his economy if he needs to to
pursue his uh
goal of making Russia Great again uh
that's why I would rather emphasize
other fronts I think we have to increase
our military support it's long past time
that member states start providing
modern battle tanks to Ukraine
I also believe that we have to work on
the Diplomatic front
through his
breach continuous breach of
international law and through his
threats with using the weapons of mass
destruction Putin is even more becoming
a pariah internationally and we should
make
clear that this is also pursued by our
diplomatic services and in the realm of
our own public opinion those are two
very important fronts thank you
thank you to conclude this first round
Mr botenga
yes thank you very much let me
um maybe I mean we speak about this this
escalation of
um the annexation illegal referenda uh
the the threat with nuclear war and and
partial mobilization
the question of course for us and and I
think what the colleague said Is is true
is how to de-escalate how to avoid uh
indeed what now zelinski calls uh no
Bluff uh meaning the threat with nuclear
weapons be it then strategic nuclear
weapons whatsoever uh that that does not
become a reality now the impression I
got from other countries reactions
China India and so on is that not only
they're not happy with this they're
actually for the moment they were not
let's say supporting uh EU sanctions
supporting the EU approach but insisting
very much on on diplomacy so my question
is here is the European Union are we
considering that these military let's
say defeats or at least setbacks for
Russia the fact that internationally
some of let's say the countries that
have not taken a stance other than a
neutral stance are not happy with what's
going on does that offer a window for
diplomacy does it offer a window for
another way of de-escalation because
sanctions as we have seen aside from the
the harm they are clearly doing to the
Russian economy they did not prevent War
they will not stop War
um is there any any way where you say
how are we going to de-escalate to avoid
for example that this thread of
um short uh term or medium term use of
nuclear weapons becomes reality thank
you
okay thank you Mr buttenga back to you
Mr Divina and please bear in mind we
have a second round waiting
thank you honorable members for these uh
quite challenging questions uh some of
them I can answer some more difficult
and and some are frankly cannot in in in
a public meeting that's also reality
um Mr Gala why sanctioned away
restrictive measures is just the legal
terminology that we have but uh actually
we do mean of course sanctions
we never disclose in advance of course
the detail of economic sanctions or of
individual listings for obvious reasons
to avoid preventive circumvention to
avoid speculation on certain
Goods that might become more expensive
or unavailable that kind of things but
the work is ongoing there will be new
export bans new import bands new sectors
some sectors will be extended
Etc and new listings of companies and
individuals
will will be published
um on on call
um the the
import by by the EU is sanctioned since
uh since August
um
the question remains now for the
shipments to third countries but inside
the EU it's it's already sanctioned uh
European companies are not allowed to
participate in shipments of call of
Russian call to third countries
and we are discussing currently with the
commission and the member states on
these matters
um
weapons ammunition do we coordinate yes
but again I do not want to give any
details in public on this type of
matters
Mr gubelius I I am I must say that um
well we can of course always hope for
more production of weapons or ammunition
of both but this is a member states
competence is complete so if we can hope
and encourage if you want
um but this is obviously not a new a new
competence
um again the steps that we have taken
with the one Ukraine unprecedented if
you if you look at what has been has
been achieved of course it's like the
proverbial glass half full half empty
you can always hope for more I do
however beg to disagree with you when
you say us are doing the job no because
the economic sanctions and the economic
bits which is important because it is
crippling uh also the war machine of of
Russia the the vast bulk is is the EU
sdu only it's not it's not the US
um
Mr simos Savage
um pardon for the pronunciation my
colleague and correct okay
um the referendum of the reservative
fundament known in advance of course yes
as I said this is this is a scenario I
like Crimea
since 2014 uh krami from the Russian
point of view is Russia of course we
completely do not recognize this at all
but I would like to say that also since
the beginning of the war Ukraine has
already also
done military strikes in in Crimea so um
there is no need to go I think into
further
rhetoric escalation uh on this on these
nuclear threats
um
uh I know that there are discussions
also bilaterally between also nuclear
powers on this on these manners
um on the questions of Russian
conscripts feeling that fleeing their
country
well
um you have two point of views some say
that the more the more the more leave
the less will be available for the Army
it's it's obvious others say that it's a
security matter because it's not because
they leave that they're against the war
or even an opponent to the government
and uh and if you start and it and you
cannot equate automatically uh certainly
not legally speaking somebody avoiding a
military conscription with political
Refugee because it doesn't transform
into an opponent so these these but
these were these are discussed with the
member states
um I discussed that yesterday and we're
trying indeed to have a coordinate
approach but it's not it's not that
simple because the EU legislation uh
Schengen code does allow for either
revocation of existing visas or not
allowing entrants uh for Visa holders
for security reasons article six of
Schengen code which is our registration
uh Mr Boogie for is China happy and
happy
we can speculate I believe China is not
happy with the adventurism of Russia
because uh what was presented as a small
special material operation that would
last a couple of hours or a couple of
days
is now never-ending prices of energy
which China is was largest importer are
increasing even if they have some
discounts or that you can there are
rumors of some discount nevertheless
it's increasing it's a problem for their
exports because most of their exports
are far away so Energy prices is a
problem
for Chinese exports uh it Crea it risks
creating a recession in their markets in
their destination this is not good for
them food prices increase they are the
World Net importers of food as well
largest net important food as well so
there are a number of things uh and if I
if I read what was said in Shanghai
Corporation organization if I also read
by the way what traditional eyes of
Russia like um like Kazakhstan uh have
said that they would not recognize these
uh illegal annexations in referendum Etc
I think that there is indeed a more and
more certain diplomatic isolation of
Russia and yes we're working a lot on
that we're also working on the Battle of
narrative
because Russian propaganda wants to
portray us as the the cause for the
problems in the world
it's a very good question we already
avoid to escalate ourselves but you know
the proverb it takes two to tango or two
to make peace and only one to make war
and
um it's uh we believe that
um making the price of the war more
expensive Russia is part of the
escalation even if it's not a magic wand
yes I agree with you that economic
consideration and certainly the
well-being of his people is not driving
Russian leadership but nevertheless I
think it's our duty to to continue
um the way we do thank you
thank you we come to our second and
Final Round And I would like to ask
colleagues to try and stick to two
minutes and the first is Francisco
milanmon
thank you chair
and thank you to Mr Davina
for the information you've given us and
for your comments thereafter
I'd like to refer to
a point that was raised by Mr budikova
I mean it's very important and you
mentioned this
that the e a s and the EU communicate
our position
efficiently this is about the narrative
War
we need to make it so that the majority
of 140 countries which condemned The
Invasion on the general assembly be
visible
it shouldn't look as though things are
balanced this needs to be translated
into facts
there's a lot of ambiguity in the
position of other countries we the EU us
the like-minded countries Australia and
Japan and another ones and Morocco
didn't vote neither did Algeria Brazil
looked the other way Etc turkey well is
a member of the of NATO but we also know
how Ambiguously they are
acting
I think that
this raises some eyebrows
lavrov has been very active under the
proactive front remember that a few
months ago the uh
African Union was asking for a uh
lifting of sanctions
there's been a lot of work with the
Kazakhstan Etc what are we doing
now I don't know what Mr Michelle has
been doing I think he was there in New
York and he often goes to Africa what
did he do in New York
tell us I don't know what he did and his
wonderline I think uh has been less
present externally because it's uh Mr
Burrell's job and Mr Michelle chop but
in terms of sanctions trade she does
have competences
therefore I think that
Mr Burrell
Mr Michelle and Ms avadon have to be
active internationally out there thank
you
thank you
next is our colleague please
thank you Mr chair I would like to
continue the discussion on
on those people who are fleeing Russia
those young men who are not ready to go
to Army and who are not ready to go to
Ukraine to kill ukrainians so
um and this is obviously it's a
competence of the commission because we
have the Schengen area and I have to say
that this is a little bit embarrassing
that at the same time we see that the
president of the council Mr Mitchell is
saying that this young men are welcome
to European union or they ought to be
welcome to European union and at the
same time there are more and more member
states who are closing their borders for
for these young men
so and this is a question which is an
urgent one because it's it's an acute
question that these people are coming
now and then we know also that Mr Putin
and uh
and the government of Russia is thinking
to close their borders so that these
young men could not have the possibility
to go abroad and and flee the military
service
so I I just would like to urge you to do
your outmost that the commission who is
a key player in in the how how to
how do singing rules ought to be
executed would create an atmosphere that
we would have United from this is
embarrassing for our people especially
in these countries who are who are near
the Russian board
thank you
next is zege lagudinski
um thank you very much thanks for your
um information a couple of points one
point is the future of sanctions or
um how is our confrontation our defense
of Ukraine support for Ukraine is going
to look like past sanctions because I
think we are coming in a situation where
sanctions have been exhausted uh and uh
the question to you is what are going to
be the main instruments the main
leverage that we will be having how
we're going to be going about about that
this is number one number two personal
sanctions uh um part of the package
probably would be personal sanctions in
which direction would you go will the 6
000 people list uh prepared by our
allies from the Civil Society of Russia
be Foundation or how what are the next
steps propaganda propagandists one of
our proposals is uh to sanction those
who are members of the Duma parties on
all levels and and enjoy and how have
offices also on Municipal level to for
example ban them and from entry to the
European Union this would be a real way
of differentiating On the Border uh
number three number two
um hybrid dimension of escalation that
is upcoming and it's not just about
propaganda it's about security concerns
it's about possible sleepers uh or who
are either here or are coming what is
the commission and what a member states
maybe you have information on that and
your services it do is doing to
strategically think about the next steps
of this escalations that would be not
just economic they would be hybrid in
terms of our security uh threat and the
last point and I will end with them
legally speaking you said on the border
there is no right of those people to
enter enter uh the European Union you
are talking about Schengen it's not
about Schengen it's about our Asylum
Seekers and the corridors for people to
apply for Asylum and even though we can
be of different opinions on how to deal
with them in terms of welcoming that
that on a large scale there must be just
as in Mediterranean an opportunity for
people to apply life or Asylum at the
border of the European Union this is
what what doesn't happen now and this
has to be addressed so what was this
addressed during the yesterday's
meetings and what are you planning to do
to combat this this risk
thank you colleague Jordan office next
uh
thank you I'm going to speak Polish uh
Mr director thank you for the
information that you've provided us with
I have two questions the first question
relates to security
when it comes to the workers in the
zapova nuclear plant my question relates
to
the protection of that nuclear power
plant by International forces
exceptional situations call for
exceptional Solutions and the war in
Ukraine is such an exceptional situation
an accident
in the turn of middle vein would be a
Global catastrophe secondly what is
being done at present when it comes to
better informing EU citizens about the
situation where we have a war in Europe
that we can't they can't expect to go on
living
as before the war the people in Europe
have to be prepared
to the difficult times that I had thank
you
thank you
next is natural sanchezamo I'm speaking
Spanish gracias
thank you chair
I won't be repeating
what colleagues have said
there's this possibility that Russia
might consider itself to be attacked
after the shame sham referenda
but there's something I want to talk
about there's going to be another vote
at the UN level and once again we're
going to have a map of The
Disappearance of
countries that are really involved we'll
see how many of them are lukewarm
we're at a point where we want to keep
our countries but our friends but we
have to no
our friends need to make it clear that
they are not like the lukewarm countries
or like those who have disappeared from
this map
this is going to be our map and our
compass for foreign policy in the months
to come we have to see which countries
are absent and which actually support
votes against Russia
so that's what we need to be looking at
and turkey has had a very ambivalent
role we all know this publicly and the
UN president Adon has used his position
as a mediator which is very happy to
have
had a domestic level as well and I know
that turkey has been receiving messages
from Parliament and from the EAS they've
been told not to play with sanctions
because some activities of turkey are
borderline
support to Russia with regards to
sanctions so we should keep our pressure
it needs to stay on
the role so far of turkey has been
positive but they cannot use it as an
excuse to carrying policies that are
very close to supporting Russia
thank you next is Viola from come on
yeah and thanks to Mr Divina for for the
information first of all I can only
stress what you have said regarding
China I think it was remarkable that she
after two and a half years of not
traveling the first destination he has
chosen was Kazakhstan who is openly an
opponent of Mr Putin and who is sad
though in Petersburg and now at the
summer Grand Summit as well and also I
mean the whole pictures which were sent
uh globally during this Summit in in
summer can't I think have mainly shown
that even the the worst dictators in the
world
uh rather ready to isolate a Putin there
and I think there was a remark
remarkable situation second of all uh
regarding food prices I mean one has to
keep in mind that China is buying each
and every ton of grain on the World
Market are you somehow in contact with
them because they are completely
separated from the global uh food prices
they keep the storages extremely high
that seems to be an interesting
strategic reserve and China Indonesia
and India together
how to say
decrease the global storages in a way
which of course affects
the experts from Russia and Ukraine even
more and it would be extremely important
to have a better Outreach to China and
India in that respect and regarding the
security I can only support what is a
gay has said I think it is important to
have a proper Asylum procedure because
there are a lot of indications now that
even I was very much sympathetic with
opening the borders for those young men
who do not want to serve in Ukraine but
there will be a lot of FSB agent amongst
them and this creates a huge security
risk for all of us I mean I I know it's
a dilemma and I have a lot of sympathy
to invite them but not just like this
thank you our final two speakers are
David Leger and Andre halitsky and then
we need to close the speakers just
because I know that group meetings begin
at nine o'clock so David
thank you chair and thank you Mr David
for taking the time to have this
exchange with us in these very troubling
times indeed um I want to start by
reiterating my colleagues remarks
regarding the need for increased support
for Ukraine but but also I wanted to
support you in in your initial
interventions regarding the distancing
that we see from both China and and
other countries right now India even
though I personally
I'm a bit skeptical regarding the
seriousness of China's distancing and
their true intentions but I wanted to
come back to Russia's friends instead
right now we see the increased
cooperation with Iran
um luckily the drones that they are
buying aren't of a good quality but but
your your thoughts regarding Russia's
Friends The increased corporations are
with Iran and how can we make sure
to
do our best to prevent Russia having
more friends and what are you doing in
that perspective
thank you thank you David and finally
and Jay
thank you very much Mr German uh my
colleagues from Bulgaria you're so good
publisher I'm obliged also to use my
native language
um
I have a very quick question
now we're talking about
the
Potential conscripts from Russia want to
come to Europe do we have any estimates
as to how many people were talking about
you have mixed feelings as far as this
issue goes
because
I mean Russian citizens should be held
accountable for what's happened and like
Mr Lego said I think we need to barter
uh sanctions package family members of
the military uh people for instance
should be hit and we have to react
more quickly
and what about beloveds are we
considering uh sanctions against
Fellowship was also responsible thank
you and to conclude Mr davinia I would
just like to make him one comment which
a number of colleagues have already
touched upon
um I stand by our European humanitarian
obligation which includes granting
humanitarian visas to Russian citizens
after a case by case assessment
but each individual Asylum application
must be carefully examined and a blanket
promise of asylum
for Russian conscientious objectors in
my point of view would simply be wrong
because every case needs to include a
security check
and
we have to be blunt not every
conscientious objector is also an
opponent of the regime of Mr Putin
because a lot of Russian men who are now
fleeing the country where they are
threatened with their own military
service
have at least not been actively against
this war perhaps even supporting this
war so I don't believe the theory that
every consensus objector is also an
opponent of Mr Putin we have to be very
careful in our examinations and the
final point is what we definitely need
is a coordinated European position on
this issue and what we're seeing here
once again is that some national
governments are rushing ahead with their
own positioning and once again we're not
showing Unity perhaps I can hear some
views from you on that point
thank you Mr chairman I will I will
start by the end I fully agree with you
now we live in the in the legal
framework that we have
um
and certainly
um Asylum procedures of course they have
no big discussion uh that there should
be
made redundant or that we should create
exceptions from the Asylum procedure we
assignment procedures of course an
individual case
and the security can security can check
Security check can take place uh with it
as well as well as checking the real
motivation uh which is indeed a
completely different
um
attitude than giving uh blanket
exemptions
um
we haven't
we do not know the numbers
um yet we have seen increase in Finland
uh serious increase uh
in Finland which is the I think the
country in the EU which has so far seen
the BET cost increase
but they're also
uh rumors that that Russians will uh
tighten the control for the exit which
so far has not been the case apparently
the reports that border control posts
were kind of conducting very artisanal
interviews on a case-by-case basis but
not having listings and I mean all
seeming seems to have been rushed very
in a way and effectively
there are also reports of bribing to be
allowed to leave etc etc so I guess we
will see the
wave effect uh in in in some time
um
Mr litzky on the Belarus I can reassure
the already sanctions on on Belarus uh
that different package but they are
existing
on um on the question of uh
The Diplomatic Outreach believe me we
spend a lot of time doing that in the
high representative the first one uh and
making known uh that uh also that the
attitude towards this war is not just
are you in the west or are you
supporting the West it's also and first
and foremost are you supporting
international law or are you supporting
a blatant violation of absolutely all
principles ranging from OIC to United
Nations that uh
military conquest or acquisition of
territory by by military force is is
illegal and we spend a lot of time on
that uh like we know in in international
relations of course
uh every every country takes its uh
it's interesting to into consideration
but there's there's a price for for
everything
um
you were you were referring
um to president Michelle speech in
United Nation General Assembly uh he
proposed clearly that a country
attracting attacking a sovereign state
should be suspended from the United
Security and the National Security
Council so I don't think he can be
accused of having ignore the matter
um
and yes there are some countries who are
ambiguous we are aware of reports of
circumvention of sanctions by turkey
particularly some other countries as
well we are examining this uh I'm
actually going to Turkey next week
um at the same time turkey has played a
positive role in the Black Sea grain
deal which was quite important both for
Ukraine and and for the world
um
and we spent also a great deal of uh
explaining to African friends
um that this is not uh us who are
driving the price of food upwards and
fighting the Russian propaganda there
and Blitz and blatant lies
um
on the question of sanctions first of
all I I don't think that economic
sanctions will be soon exhausted uh I
think that there's a lot of leeway
um you have also seen that at G7 there
are discussions of all caps all price
caps Etc so there's there's a lot more
that you can do do not forget that when
it comes to individual sanctions
that we are legally bound and that our
sanctions our review are subject to
Legal review by jurisdiction of the
European court of justice
um
and that for instance the 6000 names
that that I think you were alluding to
of the navalny compiled by navalny group
I think are most mainly linked to
corruption but corruption in is not the
legal criteria for for our current
regime it's uh rather attacking um
Independence sovereignty of Ukraine so
uh we have to do this but
uh we are definitely continuing increa
we will put individuals that are
obviously linked to the recent steps uh
with these um
referendum Etc
um
then on on the on the question of
zaporizia but also and finally two other
nuclear power plants which have been
attacked uh by by Russia and McGriff
another one with a longer name
um yes this is extremely extremely
worrying uh we've been quite active with
the international economic Atomic agency
to
to secure as much as we can
um when it comes to informing
um you EU citizens this is unfortunately
also very much the responsibility of of
national governments
um of what's going on
um traditionally you know that um
this is the case for the better or the
worse sometimes
um
yes I think I cover it all
um and yes Mrs
discussing contact with China I I'm not
aware of of this it's probably very
important to do not sure China would
necessarily listen to us if they if they
want to secure as much food as possible
for themselves but we are we are
following that uh very clearly we're
also following the the support by Iran
but you know the state of the relations
with Iran is sufficiently complicated
already
and it's frankly not so simple to
to imagine to have some more leverage on
Iran on this thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
levinia this concludes today's meeting I
would like to thank you all for your
participation and contributions would
let anyone like to raise something under
any other business that is not the case
our next meetings will be on the 12th
and 13th of October timing still to be
confirmed this meeting is closed
foreign